well las vegas slowly coming back to
life and tourists can't wait to arrive
our city has been trending online for
popular destinations for both spring
breaks summer getaways as well
christian casadas joining us in the
studio with more on what's attracting
visitors to come back
well denise i don't think many people
need a reason to come to vegas but
if you do there are several we're
talking about great shows amazing
restaurants and award-winning buffets
at a great cost now let's begin with
travel nevada does not require covet
tests like other desirable destinations
like hawaii
we checked on airfare through las
vegas's major airline southwest
flying in from chicago for spring break
for example prices
are nothing near what they normally are
but we did find some good deals and even
some
that were even sold out in terms of
hotels vegas.com listed several rooms
on the strip for the same week with low
prices and a few
with more than 50 percent off that alone
is a great start according to unlv's
assistant professor of hospitality
amanda bellarino who expects las vegas
will see brighter days
very soon las vegas has a lot of
desirability for a variety of reasons
you know one is of course
we're going to have shows again we have
more things available than a lot of
other domestic
destinations and we are known for our
world-class hospitality so i think all
of that really helps
well she also added that the fact that
our hospitality
and the food workers are going to get
vaccinated
is key to a successful spring and summer
season because tourists will feel safer
knowing that the people that will
assist them are vaccinated now we also
checked in on several shows along the
strip for
the week of spring break and we found
that many are close
to selling out now speaking of southwest
they
are now flying non-stop between las
vegas and colorado springs
which will be happening daily also
american airlines is planning to launch
non-stop flights
from here to austin starting in may so
more reasons for people
to come and visit christian casa is 8
news now